[Music]
more and more enterprises are
modernizing their infrastructure by
moving to the cloud and adopting devops
as a way to deliver better software
faster and more reliably
thanks to our friends on the devops
research and assessment team we know
that on average the best performing
organizations see a higher deployment
frequency have less lead time for
changes have a lower change failure rate
and take less time to restore services
after a failure
a big part of excelling at these four
key metrics is having a robust and
effective continuous delivery pipeline
in place if your software development
team is developing and delivering
container-based applications on gke that
can be challenging especially when
you've got dozens or even hundreds of
pipelines across multiple environments
introducing google cloud deploy a
streamlined fully managed continuous
delivery solution for gke google cloud
deploy addresses these challenges in
three ways it's fully managed and
scalable it has built-in security
controls and it integrates with your
existing devops ecosystem
since it's fully managed service that
means there's no expensive
infrastructure to set up or maintain for
your gke continuous delivery pipeline
whether you're a small startup or a
large enterprise google cloud deploy
scales your continuous delivery process
seamlessly and manages it via simple
declarative configuration and however
your operation scales you can have a
centralized view of all of your
pipelines releases and deployments
across all of your google cloud projects
google cloud deploy was designed with
safety and security in mind
by leveraging iam for easily defined and
granular access controls you'll be able
to designate the right people to manage
release promotions and roll out and roll
back changes to each environment with a
few quick clicks
and google cloud deploy provides audit
logs right out of the box enabling you
to meet your regulatory and compliance
goals as you scale your release velocity
google cloud deploy is designed to work
with your existing devops ecosystem of
products google cloud deploy
functionality is accessible via cli or
api and is able to integrate with
popular tools you already love like
cloud build and jenkins for continuous
integration google cloud deploy also
brings scaffolds to your pipelines
improving the reliability of pipelines
by insulating them from changes to your
tool chain and application architecture
sound good you can learn more about
google cloud deploy by checking out
cloud.google.com
deploy
[Music]